gross render challenges
i really wish i hadn't seen that
how do we rise above these gross videos
you know you have to think more
abstractly
i'm not looking forward to this one
a huge thanks to razer and nvidia studio
for sponsoring this video and be sure to
stick around if you guys want to know
more about the world's fastest laptops
built for creators
let's
get
gross together
let's
get
gross together okay let's
get
gross again
[Music]
so this week we are doing a render
challenge and you guys have probably
seen some of our other render challenges
before but the goal in those videos was
to make something satisfying this time
around however the goal is a little bit
different it's gonna be yucky it's gonna
be real yucky it's gonna be real gross
and yuppy i'm not looking forward to
this one this was an idea that was
thrown out in the comments and it stuck
with us gross render challenge wha what
does that mean yeah i think it would be
very helpful to me if we could define
some sort of boundaries
[Music]
i understand why you need to make that
statement
right now we've got an idea gross render
challenge but we got to establish what
that means what is your definition of
gross okay i mean well there of course
are those pimple popping like blackhead
removal videos on the internet the
grossest thing i've ever seen i don't
know what movie it's from but it's an
it's like an old film maybe you know
this is from of an eyeball getting cut
gross in my mind is anything that like
evokes like a visceral cringey reaction
like because our brains literally
evolved to not eat rotten food not eat
poisonous plants that taste gross stuff
like rotten stuff slimy stuff body
fluids oh pretty much anything bodily
related is gonna be gross our bodies are
gross things
one of the worst feelings in the world
is watching a video where someone pulls
a hair from like their throat like
that doesn't make you
you ever see when people have like
some sort of insect growing inside them
and they tweeze it out like some kind of
worm or something like that boils come
to mind man just anything that is like
skin that is just waiting to burst
filled with liquid is immediately
off the table i have a big lump on my
left leg above my knee
oh he's in need of medical attention
that's a pimple no it's a it's a sister
it's just this
i didn't even look and i just
i'm never eating clam chowder again
i want to see the cyst right now
i'm clenching my teeth as hard as i
possibly can
uh fun fact about sam
i got assist in my throat once in the er
like this wait at one hour and this guy
comes in at 11 pm he's like all right
what's wrong
the throat and he's like cool open wide
and he takes his knife out and he's like
and like i'm like and then he's like
start spitting
[Laughter]
into a dish just like that
[Laughter]
no dude
but think about this like we're looking
at these gross things simply recreating
someone's balloon size cyst
dumping
pus
i mean why would we create a cgi
replication when there is an image of it
you know you have to think more
abstractly this is this is why we're
making renders here we're not just
taking like gross shots with our phones
of us popping pimples in the mirror how
do we rise above these gross videos i i
got an idea i'm excited about it's
there's so many tick tocks i watch i
need to confront them
i'm like i'm not even kidding i'm
legitimately nauseous i did not expect
that texture of group to come out it was
curdled it was curdled pus
i'm a little worried about ren to be
honest i don't know if he can get
through this one
okay i did not expect to actually
legitimately get nauseous from that i
have a very weak stomach
rarely have we had a corridor video that
i instantly regretted
if we can make
rem vomit
we have succeeded okay whoever whoever
gets the closest to making red throw up
wins that's the that is the bar for
success curdled pass on three curdle
puss one two three turtle puss
today i got up i stepped onto the grill
and i clamped down on my foot there's
not much in this world that i find more
repulsive than feet i don't know what it
is about them i just don't like them i
don't like the smell i don't like the
taste i'm kidding i don't like the look
i love the taste bunions hard skin on
the bottom of feet like uh janky
toenails they're just uh they're just
repulsive all the way around and so what
better way to cap off this entire render
challenge than including one of my
biggest phobias nasty filthy feet and so
today ren's going to help me scan my
foot
um because he's a good friend what i'm
going to do i'm going to take my foot
and i'm going to go drag it around in
the dirt and the muck so it looks nice
and disgusting
oh my gosh
then wren will gently and lovingly
capture a 3d scan on my foot that's
pretty good that's a taste looks pretty
good ball come on now that's good dude
and now with that skin done i'm gonna
try to
add some boils or some pimples or some
varicose veins all the juicy
uh repugnant little details i told
jordan okay i will scan your foot
but you gotta scan my head for the this
the first satisfying render where i had
like the scan on my face that was using
bella's 3d it's like the most simplistic
head scan you could possibly have but
this time around i'm using polycam which
will actually scan my head properly and
give me a much higher fidelity model
jordan made a major mistake
jordan made a mistake
he told me that he's afraid of this
little thing called trypophobia which is
a fear of holes it's the fear of shia
labeouf make your dreams come true
so i looked at some images of
trypophobia on hands like holes in hands
god
oh
i'm not tryphaphobic what the heck man i
mean dude look at that
this sort of like trypophobia aesthetic
reminds me a lot of david brodeur he has
like all these really good-looking
renders from a few years back that
basically
have these holes and like these little
things coming out of them jordan didn't
realize this when he told me that he's
got this fear of trypophobia that's why
i needed the head scan
i'm gonna add some holes to my face
so coming right out of the box
these polycam scans are pretty high
resolution i need to like
remesh it a little bit so i'm gonna make
the face very high resolution but the
rest of the body and head to be kind of
like low resolution in terms of like
number of polygons and i've actually
been doing this so far on this laptop
here which is pretty nuts dude this
laptop is powerful i'm a big fan so like
i'm able to actually use octane render
on this thing i mean look at look at the
skin shader i've got going to see how my
nose and like cheek are transparent
there that's the subsurface scattering i
got going on yeah so this is the razer
blade 17 which means it has a 17 inch
screen it's 4k 144 hertz this thing runs
octane render easily because it's got a
freaking gtx 3080 ti inside of it inside
of a laptop this thing was just
announced at ces this year it's got 16
gigabytes of ddr6 memory in this thing
like i said the 3080ti what's also
really nice about this is like nothing
crashes
and i guess a lot of that really comes
down to like the nvidia studio drivers
like they rigorously test all of their
drivers to make sure that you can be
running tons of different programs at
the same time and it won't crash which
is really nice there's this thing called
like rapid core scaling some programs
actually work better on like single
threads or like a couple threads rather
than like many many threads and so
nvidia is actually able to identify
which programs require less and only
give it that much and that saves a lot
of battery energy if you're just out on
the go it's more efficient overall and
you find that like it's actually even
faster i'm a big fan of this bigger
screen here but the razer blade 15 has
all of these features in fact they've
got a whole line of laptops with nvidia
studio working across all of them really
well
really cool stuff so yeah i guess it's
time to get to work here i'm going to
start poking some holes in my face you
got some clippers
uh so i saw the moment when ren saw that
giant cyst burst and he nearly lost it i
saw his soul trying to escape his body
and i thought what better inspiration
for how to make ren throw up than what
already almost made him throw up so i'm
thinking my render will probably involve
some sort of boil or zit that gets
popped and explodes with some kind of
gelatinous goo
that's just leaking out of a body
because um who doesn't love a good leak
so the next step is to grab my roommate
riley who i use for all of my 3d scans
he's basically in a walking asset
library so i'm just going to grab him
i'm going to 3d scan an area of his neck
and also his hand so we can have super
realistic textures for the render to
make it all the more gross the foot scan
turned out pretty good actually i added
like a bunch of little boils all along
the surface
i mean lots of little bulging sporty
pimples
just makes it worse and then you just
start layering in wounds
it's like a leper's foot but i want to
rig it so the toes wriggle you know i
want the toes to move so that you are
aware that this person's alive and that
makes it worse i think it's like living
foot cheese
sorry oh
living foot cheese sorry i thought i
could i thought oh man
yeah it's coming together i'm feeling
pretty good about it i've got like the
machine element built for this thing i
just got to get onto the simulations now
we are kind of running low on time at
this point so i got to stop focusing on
this foot it's nasty enough like this
has made me physically sick a couple
times a day like genuinely i've had to
stop and sit and breathe
but it's getting
less extreme that's an arc right there
i'm growing i'm changing i don't know if
it's for the better now that i'm
thinking about it but
feet are not as repulsive as they were
at the beginning of this thing i think
this is good enough i think for now i'm
gonna move on to the simulation
yeah
okay so i got the scan in there i got
the pimple all animated i got the
tweezers and the hand working but then i
hit a snag and that was
the bane of my existence and the thing i
always try to avoid liquid simulations
simulations in general in computer
graphics have gotten a lot better over
the last few years now we have things
like embergen which is a real-time smoke
simulator it used to take hours and
hours to simulate smoke now it takes
seconds but with liquid simulations it's
like you just
you go like this and then you hit
simulate and then once it's done
you're like
that looks like
awful and you have to do that probably a
thousand times
changing little settings here and there
and and with a lot of things in cg you
can kind of get away with some jankiness
but with liquid it's like we all are
intimately aware of what liquid looks
like so if there's jank it's it's very
evident and if i want ren to throw up i
have to get this right there's no margin
of per error here
oh man this is stressful
all right so i've got a bit of an update
oh man dude i even got like a little
flab of skin i hope i can actually
incorporate that in the end so this is
like actually a really cool technique i
used this thing called voronoi fracture
to add holes to my face ren
don't please dude
literally of all the things you could do
hey when don't do please dude
that's so gross i can't look at that
dude
good
i hate it
i don't know i find this to be kind of
pleasing to be honest like this is weird
and creepy looking i i selected some of
these polygons kind of like around my
face here i detached it so it's a whole
separate 3d object and i ran that
through a voronoi fracture system which
breaks it up it's usually meant for like
physics simulations but i was able to
take the edges between all those
polygons and extrude them out and
thicken them and then volumize it and
smooth it into what you're seeing here
so this is very creepy looking jordan
you're gonna love this man
wait are you freaked out by like these
little holes in the laptop here no that
see that does nothing to me don't do
this
yeah not gonna lie it's been a really
gross time but it's been a good time
working on this laptop here it's it's
super dope to be able to have like
desktop power on my lap here and if you
want to learn more about nvidia studio
or get your own razer blade 15 or 17
like this one click that link in the
description and you won't be sorry i'm
going to add a little facial animation
to this thing and render it out i've
only got tonight to do it so i guess all
we have left is to see what the other
guys did
here we are with our finished renders
ready to be displayed to everyone hold
on to your stomachs my stomach's
currently right side up and i'm hoping
it stays that way but i don't i'm not
not so sure jake's eating egg behind me
dude
i smell egg oh man egg makes no i'm sick
so my whole approach with this render
was specifically to try to gross jordan
out i feel like i broke something in me
in this process and i'm not sure i'll
ever be back to normal
friend count us down all right three two
one
wow
little goopy puss in the gaps
[Laughter]
it's so gross i like can't look away but
it's making me very uncomfortable
it's kind of giving me like
i like barely beaten this morning so
it's making me nauseous looking at the
green stuff so the animation i use this
app called moves by maxon it works with
cinema 4d and basically i just set it
down and i i did what you're seeing
there and it spits out like this shape
of a face that i was able to line up
with the 3d model and then do basically
a
a mesh cage style thing remember when i
did like that yeah that basketball hoop
uh net on that render i think this is an
excellent gross render it's awesome it
looks great it's creative me not grossed
out this is like seven on the gross
meter that's pretty nasty grossest cg
i've ever seen it's like an eight
i'm gonna give a six out of ten six out
of ten is still very gross ten out of
ten is like either i'm vomiting or i'm
fainting you know i still had to
actually make something and not die so i
couldn't i couldn't push it past the six
from my own point of view like if it's
too gross you can't even physically make
it because you die
all right peter let's see if he can make
me lose my non-breakfast i
my aim is to have you uh
do two
let's do it
oh my god yeah this was like not fun to
make no it was really fun to make but
also disturbing okay
okay here we go
this is like the thing that made me sick
don't oh god three
two okay
[Music]
what is it
[Laughter]
is
dude when it burst out i actually did
like freaking i don't even know what you
call it did you hurt yeah that's what
happened that's what you call it okay
it's the whole opening more you know
what i mean like seeing into an open
wound is i'm done for you the hole was
particularly challenging this would be
really gross except you just couldn't
resist getting a little cute at the end
it just gets a little cute
it's a little cute
i don't know if that's cute that's good
what's going on look at that it's a
little baby going like wow
i i'm very uncomfortable this is like an
eight out of ten i'm as you see i'm
still like conscious so it's an eight if
friends was like say
uh seven on the gross meter this is like
a 6.9
nice that's right i'm ranking you
grossest cg i've ever seen in my entire
life i think this is like an eight and a
half
maybe even a knife
yes
i don't know of a grosser cg
image well that was the grossest render
you've ever seen until maybe
jordan i don't know if i can top that
but i'll try
you know i was told to put this down on
the table for uh you know max effect
that has nothing to see what happened
[Music]
that was tasty that's good dandruff
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't eat it don't eat oh
i knew you were doing the freaking foot
thing obviously i helped you with that i
didn't expect the freaking pus channel i
was doing the foot shavings and that was
gross but i thought how much worse would
it be if you had just a nice full boil
ready to share with uh the hungry
restaurant goers
uh yeah here we are this looks amazing
like the attention to detail in in the
machinery and how the little claw like
takes it and like moves it like that and
then moves away what'd you do for the
noodles is that a 3d model of noodles so
in houdini i did three different types
of simulations i did the particles for
the skin i did the liquid for the actual
pus and i did uh a tetrahedral soft body
sim
come on dude that should be illegal
one more for daddy there you go okay
very hard to put this in your mouth
there you go
we lost what no you guys it's super
gross but like it's it's it's a very
nice package you know
it's like a little happy meal you know
it's great it loops it's really well
composed it's like gross and still
abstract this is an 8 out of 10 on the
growth scale but it's a 10 out of 10 on
the render scale
my heart is full thank you my friend
grossest render i've ever seen
definitely right up there with peter's
eight and a half nine even but the thing
that puts it over the top for me
is it it tells a story
i think it's the render that got me to
uh elicit the most a vocal reaction i'm
revising peter's score from a 6.9 to a
seven so it's a tie with ren and this
7.01
and nail biter
well that was a lot of fun to work on i
wasn't able to actually do everything
that i wanted to do so there's a slight
bit of disappointment on my end but i
kind of regret doing this video because
of what i saw you guys make you you made
me sick
i mean we lit we literally made a goal
between us to make you sick
i feel less bad about trying to make you
feel sick then well see that's what i
was saying when you found out my phobia
and took advantage of it i suddenly felt
very vindicated for a private
conversation
i want to do another gross render
challenge at some point here soon i need
suggestions down in the comments on some
gross ideas what do you want to split
what do you want to boil what do you
want to tear open what do you want what
do you want to fester yeah enough enough
this is done we're done